today marks the end of Black History
Month black owned businesses in Nevada
they are growing Candace Charles looks
at the state of the industry and ways to
keep it growing
in marketing this is Amaya how may I
help you 22 year old Amaya Eden is
getting a jump start on future as a
business owner she's been working at Sam
new marketing since she was 14. there's
been a lot of growing opportunity for me
her grandfather Sean Dale Newsom started
the business in 2006. it's just changing
the whole landscape of what we saw you
know my father used to say something
like don't don't get bitter get better
there are close to 300 000 small
businesses in Nevada more than 26 000
are black owners according to the U.S
small business administration knew some
hopes to see that number improve in the
future it's very important that the
community and even the young people in
our community get to see us and there is
a lot to see according to analysis done
Cruz the number
28 percent higher in the third quarter
of 2021 and then it was pre-pandemic the
biggest change for any group it's just
all about Innovation and creativity and
survival the biggest challenge for us as
black owned businesses is the employer
firms Newsome is the co-chair of small
business for America's future he tells
me that minority business development
agency or mbda helps to fill the gaps
you need more resources that are going
to add capital and not not only Capital
but technical assistance because once
you get the capital now you have to
understand how to run the business and
you have to understand what are the
nuances of when you get in trouble what
do you need to do well with
representation in our community the
future looks brighter I've been getting
familiar with the business and how to
run it and how it operates